[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett joining us today once again from
VidCon where we recorded a handful of
biscuits our Michael Gregory Evan
Gregory and Sarah fullen Gregory three
of the four founding members of the
musical quartet the Gregory Brothers
Band that's best known for their YouTube
series
auto-tune the news and songified this
and longtime friends of ours which will
become very clear as you begin the
biscuit with us their YouTube channel
known as schmoyoho accent on the yo was
created back in 2006 by Michael and I
dug up some interesting stuff on there
by sorting about oldest first that's a
little trick I'll let you in on it's
quite a trick link they all sort button
oh yeah at YouTube but it became the
home for all things Gregory brother
thanks to auto-tune and the presidential
debate six years ago since its start the
channel has racked up 2.5 million
subscribers and over six hundred and
eighty million views and a lot of those
views are attributed to the success of
their masterfully auto-tune song
applications where they digitally
manipulate the voices of politicians
news anchors other characters from viral
videos to create these insanely catchy
songs accompanied by a hilarious video
often that employs a lot of green screen
and sometimes a keytar and they may not
have invented the software for auto-tune
they did not they simply could not but
everybody they can certainly be credited
for making it the sensation it became
back in 2009 and 2010 I'm sure you
remember the Charlie Sheen winning song
almost 57 million views today and with
36 million views the internet classic
double rainbow song
but their most popular video today is
the bedroom intruder song which
currently has 128 million views and I
know that you remember this one now guys
that was the most watched video on
YouTube so I guess that means the planet
in 2010 yeah that's big so of course the
success of their auto-tuning and songa
fication skills has led them to various
other projects a lot of which we talked
about in this ear biscuit we had a great
time sitting down with three of the four
Gregory's talking about the history of
how they became music magicians they're
magicians it's hard for me to say
musicians especially when I'm fixated on
magicians how they became a band and a
youtube sensation we talked about how
Evan and Sarah met we talked about how
all of them met rich which is by birth
many most of them met library um what
led to the creation of auto-tune the
news and how their online success open
the doors for many other projects like I
said like making an auto-tune segment
for the Oscars and creating the theme
song for the TV show unbreakable kimmy
schmitt yeah so we enjoyed talking with
the gentleman and the lady and we think
you'll enjoy this here biscuit but first
we want to take a moment to let you guys
know about our song biscuits animated
series you remember song biscuits where
we collaborated with other youtubers to
create songs based on your suggestions
we should have had the Gregory Brothers
on that but it didn't work out that I
don't have to be for season two yeah
we'll bring it back at some point but
what we have done is we pick some of our
favorite song biscuits from that series
and partner with some of our friends
over at Frederator yeah to get some of
their animators to bring these to life
in animated form so we're doing that on
Saturdays on the good mythical morning
channel so make sure you check those out
but now let's get on with the biscuit
how often does that happen you show up
somewhere and it's like some news thing
and they're like can you sing our like
callsign or whatever oh yeah literally
every time you three call signs today
just today yeah yeah mostly for serious
kids and our signing kids in our signing
line who are like my youtube channel is
called well Bobby McGee production and
you grant this request you're that nice
oh yeah we love doing what we don't
grant is when someone is like so have
you auto-tune your baby crying yet now
you have the answer the question you
just made fun of I really want to know
so where's Andrew he's missing
great question Andrew is on his
honeymoon he's just been married Andrew
got married honeymoon in Costa Rica oh
the Costa Rica we went to the Rica coast
would I have been to the Costa Rica he's
probably learning to surf or something
well I you know we're finally getting
you guys on in your biscuit I mean it's
we we see each other we've been friends
for so long it's just been a question of
when are we all gonna get together and
now Andrews missing out and that you
know what if it will be married and
honeymoon is literally here and so be it
lamest excuse will be rubbing this in
for a long time let's talk about the
first meeting let's reminisce on this
thing oh my gosh great idea so Michael
you're gonna have to help me figure out
how this works and then there's the
there's the initial thing about what we
did once we got there with the recording
you you you remember that so I want to
talk about I will remember but oh yeah
now I'm remembering a lot so I think I
reached out I don't know how I like sent
an email it was like you guys are
auto-tune in the news and it was amazing
and somehow we started talking right
yeah yeah you know yeah and I can't
remember what email was up like at the
time but I must have had the email
up in the videos or something and then
we were emailing each other like you
done in like the channel section like
channel information email thing right
because I was like on this kick that's
like if I really like somebody I'm gonna
I'm enough I'm gonna find him and we
were going to New York for 7 8 9 July 8
2009 right YouTube gathering and sounds
like we're going to New York that's
where the Gregory Brothers are so let's
make this happen
and you guys help me out because I was
new to the YouTube so I didn't even know
that existed so otherwise I would have
missed the whole thing I was like oh
there's a 789 I I was but you had to
agree to meet us first which was like
ruh we never like I'd never like
cold-called a youtuber cold email to
youtuber and be like hey look I really
like what you're doing let's meet on the
corner of 156 yeah I remember feeling
this sense of there was I was taking it
like it an emotional risk and sending
the email I mean I don't think we had
been cold-called ever before really so
we were we were feeling the same thing
we had jitters butterflies yeah and we
had just gotten our first iPhones Wow
yeah one of the features on the iPhone
was the voice memo thing revolution and
I just remembered the first time we ever
recorded a voice memo I was like it
sounds so clear audio so good we could
be like and then Rhett was like this
pitch this idea to me was like we could
be like NPR just using the voice memo
all my phone because this sounds like
NPR and we're like what we're going to
New York
we're going to New York and what we're
gonna do is instead of like doing video
I mean how stupid would that be - like
we thought it was a great idea it's
gonna like not vlog but just to record
audio vignettes and we would like take a
picture and then like have the audio on
our website and so the first ever
interview we did we all loved that we
met and then we went to your house came
over to our apartment we had nachos or
something we had uh-huh we had we had
that um what was that we had that beer
with the clam sauce in it which a lot of
michelada yeah I
never heard of that never had it since
you got a good - caught a beer yeah with
what we were made OG for some reason
when we made nachos we were like
committing to a full Mexican theme on
the dinner the clam beer it's it's it
can be different things but I think the
basic michelada is tomato juice and
Worcestershire is that right I thought
there was Clamato Clamato and chili
pepper in your beer yeah okay in Tecate
so we drank some of that at your
your-your-your round table there yes I
mean you do remember this yeah it's
really cute I remember he put the phone
we like sat around the little family
table and we interviewed you just like
this yeah yeah yeah it was just an
iPhone I think I think there was a
little bit of like how do you auto-tune
and there was a little bit of like
talking shop and then it was recently
found it
Oh for real it's still it's online it's
like on a no but I recently found it
like in my like voice memo yeah you know
it's years it just keeps passing along
you know it just goes from phone to
phone it is labeled it just says like 7
July 7th or July 8th whatever day that
where's my limo 13 yeah kitchen talking
to and then afterward we went we went to
watch Bruno which just came out it was
probably opening week Borat oh it was
great it was like groundbreaking and
this is like his follow up later in a
total date I remember yeah like yeah we
did it we makes you that we made you
guys dinner and then we do the full date
experience but there was a scene in the
movie where it's like a it's like a
full-on close-up of a penis yeah just
dangling and wagging wagging and it
started speaking
yeah points that you and then start
speaking yeah
and that's quite a first date you don't
want to see that on a date especially
every time I look at you guys I see that
piece it's like a date number three
movie right where you've already
established an atmosphere of mutual
respect and affection for penises yeah
yeah yes something you have to sort of
work your way up I mean thanks to that
choice I Google is there a talking penis
in this before I see any movie now right
it's on kids in mind there's the talking
penis section like right Common Sense
Media will tell you that that's luck
that's a spoiler you're willing to find
out about yes yes I won't require to
find it I have to know when to close
actually I'm not being spoiled is the
spoiler if you it would spoil the movie
actually the face book but we remain
friends Yeah right like that was
beautiful well we have to recreate that
evening you haven't made nachos in a
while actually great John written Lee
are you guys place no we were there for
several years we moved we're still in
Brooklyn just still in the same
neighborhood all of us lived in Brooklyn
somehow we landed a three-bedroom
apartment and like the one of the
coolest neighborhoods in Brooklyn and I
think the landlord it was just one of
these situations where he that kind of
forgot he owned this property and you're
confused yeah and then eventually like
years after we'd been in there at the
same price point forever he like was
like oh wait a minute
do you remembered we live there and then
raise the rent like crazy really think
anybody does you know it's just some New
York real estate talk for you you New
Yorkers love to talk about real estate
rent yeah well you like to talk about
traffic yeah we talk about traffic you
talking about rent right it's true and
you know what like is the LA traffic
that much worse than New York traffic
you're getting us that you want us to
talk about it no let's not talk about it
I just mean you shouldn't talk about it
because you don't have to get into the
New York traffic if you don't want
that's a good point that's a good point
you're right you can't avoid it you got
to talk about it yeah you're there and
the weather which is always the same
which is weird
let me talk about it right hold the
weather's still the same yes so if I'm
continuing to track our friendship
before we get in anything anyone else
will be interested in write to me the
next defining point in our internet
meets real life friendship is probably
VidCon number one yeah because it was in
Beverly Hills it was in LA at an injury
Century City yeah I had the attached
mall like outdoor mall with the rock
sugar yeah we had sushi and the at some
point either you're one a year too
because it became a semi tradition the
wives were there yeah well yeah I mean
you what you're a wife and you were
there yeah but I was so happy to have
some other wives in the party yes right
we really took it to the other level
yeah when like the wives showed up yeah
we don't even bring them to VidCon
anymore it's what they elect not to
combat we're not willing to come right
once we were all going out to eat at
Rock sugar after a vid kind of felt very
date-like and I felt we were in a
long-term courtship we are are we what
is this all leading to okay we we can
turn that into this possibly or we can
go back we can go back to the beginning
of the Gregory family because you can
talk about Andrew at length because he's
not here to defend himself that's one
thing to keep in mind but so we're
talking about what growing up in
Virginia Radford Virginia yeah yeah good
memory yeah Michael and me and Andrew
were all actually in real life real
brothers were were until we started
working together then we legally severed
the brother relations and is that is
that that's all the siblings yeah okay
yeah well not like it's not like the
Payton family and there's like one
brother that's like yeah I'm not part of
this right no or the Manning family not
the Payton feeling me anything
yeah well he's trying he was part of it
he was right but yeah yeah but yeah 100%
of us three brothers are in the YouTube
business Sarah married me and now it's
the four of us but
the heck are we talking about Radford
Virginia yes we going back to the
beginning will you like singing ensemble
at a young age wasn't there something
with the parents taking you guys on the
road with like playing spoons and
something we had church family type
stuff Oh totally we I mean our parents
are not professional musicians they're
teachers but they're both very musical
so there was always music around the
house now we're three years apart each
those three years from me - Andrew three
more years - Michael so that's family
planning when you're like 10 and you're
young as brothers for you're not gonna
be like singing in the same ensemble for
a while but there was a point at which
our parents did start pimping us out as
a like family band and we'd go sing it
like the local Lions Club or stuff like
that really right well I like we're
going pro trying to sing you know at
theater yeah we were singing for friends
at a club what were you what were you
singing I remember I remember
performance of in the jungle and when
I'm 84 for a friend's birthday was this
along there's like a cassette tape
playing or was this like no no we
brought instruments Oh dad would be
strumming the acoustic guitar oh yeah oh
and I remember when we played at that
Club this one time he we would get our
pitch from a tuning fork and you know
you hit the tuning fork and it goes when
you like hold it against your forehead
or really close to your ear
yeah but if you don't listen to it
really close the first tone you here is
actually just really high-pitched and
it's completely different pitch it's
probably like as far away as you can get
like let's if the the correct pitch is
like an a it's like a D or something
really and so I still remember getting
what you're supposed to do with it
you're supposed to hold a tuning fork
against an instrument like a guitar that
resonates and then you can clearly hear
a pitch but if you don't know that then
you're just holding it up in the air and
it's playing a completely different note
so we have this disaster at a early
family performance where there's like
three of us children waiting for dad to
give us the note so we can start singing
or whatever and like three times in a
row he would go like you know the note
we need is like or something completely
different and he's like okay and then we
would start the song
within like five seconds is an utter
train wreck we cut off and you know the
only
of information we needed was hold the
fork against the guitar and that would
have fixed every I didn't know that yet
or doesn't have a harmonica yeah
eventually it was like we're just not
getting this but it's too embarrassing
it's too embarrassing to start over
again we're actually gonna sing through
the whole thing in this awful key that
yeah we could handle the singing in the
guitar playing but not that tuning for
[Music]
listening who are currently misusing the
tuning fork I would be doing because I
didn't know about this either like
there's not enough room to put
instructions on it yes right
well now you would never stand for that
yeah now we have the iPhone playing the
ocarina but you still have to put that
against your guitar so musical from
pretty early on and I mean what was the
was it like oh this is kind of an
obligation this is what we're doing
especially with the three year
difference you're six years older you
know you're the oldest right yeah you're
the youngest handers in the middle so
it's like you know I see how my kids
interact being five years apart
it's like though they love being
together but it's just like it's a lot
of peace in certain social settings
there's like this embarrassment of each
other or just like well you know this
isn't this isn't cool was that happening
yeah yeah sure we we always got along to
a certain extent and then you have
rivalry over like you know different
things are going on at home music or
whatever but I I can't say there was a
lot of rivalry around music because of
age difference you know it's like you're
at different levels writing the piano or
guitar singing or whatever and and we
would just kind of as a stunt play in
the family band or do you know piano
recitals together whatever we weren't
really collaborating as peers until we
got to be more like college-age and
everybody is kind of come into their own
music alone mm-hmm basically and people
are starting to write music or perform
themselves and then we started to
collaborate together a little bit more
so if I'm gonna backtrack from like the
auto-tune the news break out
when did I were you at Michael were you
out of college when that happened yeah I
graduated and was interning and came up
with it at the time okay so if we if we
back up from that you how were you guys
married no the in fact I guess to back
up from auto-tune the news which kind of
broke out in 2009 but that yeah but the
premise for the series had been started
by Michael the previous fall in 2008
really the first time we ever worked
together as a quartet was the year
before in 2007 where as a quartet we
went on tour just as a band and we're
performing our own original music Andrew
had come out with his own like folk
album basically and Sarah had an EP of
soul music and how did how did you two
meet Sarah and I met in Brooklyn just I
met her when she was singing backup for
another friend like at a music venue in
in Brooklyn and said oh so you moved to
New York first yeah it was just like
right out of school
yeah within a year maybe yeah in it what
and what was the first it was to be a
musician I mean in theory that's the
hope it's like oh I would I would love
to try to do music I want to be like a
music degree I had a music degree I also
had a degree in computer science but I
was like we grew up in a small town
let's try a different environment where
I can meet musicians that are like that
are really doing it and and just try to
get in the game a little bit but I
didn't have a job when I moved there and
no game plan other than what I just very
poorly articulated so I had a terrible
year of just like trying to grab gigs
here and there
what kind of gigs what you mean I
directed a children's choir for a while
on Staten Island it's a terrible idea I
I what I say sounds like a movie in and
of itself I was you know 23 or 24 or
whatever I sang lead in a classic rock
cover band where every other member of
the band was 45 and we would play dive
bars how did you get that job was that
like answering like pulling off one of
those paper tabs in like a restroom
somewhere well I um
that gig the classic rock gig came about
because I was playing drums
in a musical production of Godspell and
the guitar player in the pit orchestra
was like a you want to come over my band
jams at this bar after practice come on
come on over and I went over and then
they found out I could sing and it just
ended up you know being that and we
started doing gigs every weekend
what was your signature cover you're as
cold as ice Oh classic yeah you know I
did get one weird gig in those days when
I was kind of taking anything I could
get from literally what you said a
pull-tab on a flyer back in like the pre
Craigslist days of like paper flyers on
a boarded up store where I pulled the
number and I called it and it was just
like vocalist needed you like rescued
this guy this how did it happen
because you were doing your own music
thing in New York as well where are you
from you did you cool his papert a
little bit he was like I need a vocalist
I grew up in Texas and went to school in
Dallas and moved to New York to pursue a
career in acting
oh I did one show it was cast in one
show in New York and I was like I don't
think that's just for me measure for
measure oh of course I know nothing of
that we're talking a theater yeah yeah
measure and I was like this sucks
so I had I would have always done music
as well and so I was getting a lot more
work as a musician than a actor and so I
just kind of transitioned into that and
that's sort of where Evan Evans in my
world overlapped well what was the
moment you know it was there is it there
an epic story of moments realizing you
were singing and harmony without
intending to what was it we met through
a bunch of mutual friends and
immediately I was like oh I was dating
another guy at the time and I was like
man bummer because that
evan is like the guy the kind of guy
always wanted to be with but oh well I'm
in this other relationship and that went
on for like a year
oh wow so you're just friends and you
know this guy Evan yeah he's a great guy
wonderful guy not the guy for me I'm not
the girl for him so anyway I realized
that eventually and then switch Evan
Evan and I got together and then I moved
away from New York oh really yeah I was
like I've had it so I moved back to
Texas and Evan just like made it work
long distance I moved to Texas to know
the first yeah first year of our
relationship was long-distance at the
time I had like kind of failed to make
the music thing work full-time I was
still playing in bands nights and
weekends but I had taken a job doing
computer stuff and basically I would
just scam the game where we would have
like a I worked in New York let's say
there was a meeting in Chicago or
something like that okay they're gonna
fly me to Chicago what if my return trip
just accidentally went to Texas whoops
oh yeah long layover yeah I kind of like
how ten-day layover weird
there's a storm flight traffic I end up
here so I basically just works that
ankle super hard for about nine months
and would visit Sarah you know once
twice a month there was something and
I'd say that pretty much kept our
relationship alive in true and then
right from there we went on tour with
his brothers okay meanwhile as you guys
were sorting out who you were as people
Michael you are at appstate just a
little baby like Boone North Carolina
yeah North Carolina there's things that
pop up like I try to start piece to
piecing together from like the YouTube
channel what's like still up there very
early on like like this Oh who's this
like okay nerdy dude with like a big
fanny pack doing like rapping like Tupac
a twist on a stage this is an app state
these videos on your YouTube channel I
thought I hit all those
we found at least one and there was like
there was that there was an American
Idol audition thing or was that really
yeah yeah that wouldn't be on my channel
but yeah that actually happened
two out of three Gregory Brothers have
been on American Idol it's true and you
took the line who's the second alright
who was first ever it was first so you
you went in for an audition on American
Idol yeah yeah
as in reason seer uh oh yeah totes bro
okay yeah that was actually season two
so that the show had only been on the
air for one year and it broke huge that
yeah very good at producing stars at
that time yeah yeah they were one for
they were one for one with Kelly
Clarkson well one for two if you count
Justin I was big into that season too
sure so but I don't I mean I didn't know
you at the time I guess but you you were
on they showed your audition as part of
the show yeah I went to Hollywood the
whole thing didn't show that audition
though right no just so there are more
people in they can show they haven't
legit made it yeah you can see that yeah
in the Hollywood episode you see me just
like flashes here and there but but I
didn't go on from Hollywood says like
they didn't invest my storyline or
whatever but you can you can see me in
those episodes it was the season early
in Ruben what was your audition you're
out your song you're your live audition
i sang a few because really what they
hide on the show somewhat is that
there's like five rounds to get
hollywood you know what you see is the
encounter with simon Apollo but you've
already been screened through four
auditions at that point so that they're
getting the people they want on TV in
front of the celebrity judges so and now
I can't even remember all the different
things that I said saying this like at
least you know first you're in like a
cattle call with 10,000 people and you
walk up to the front of the line and
some producers and and they're like okay
go and you sing for like 20 seconds and
then they literally turn around and give
a thumb up or thumb down gladiator-style
to like a security person behind you and
you either just like you either get all
through the floor you're done or you get
a bracelet and you get
go back like a day later to the next
thing and then you're singing for like
an executive producer or whatever and
you have the like tag that looks like
you're in a marathon on your shirt
so anyway by the time I made it to the
sub Dodgers I was singing sitting on the
dock of the bay still playing that old
man but playing the old man bit singing
those love it they love the oldies on
America great stick because Evan looks
like he's 13 and he's singing yeah and
like an old like man look at this own
soul I did the the greatest part of it
for me was this is a in a pre youtube
pre rick roll era and simon cowell
compared me to Rick Astley you got
impressions oh yeah so I you know you
finished singing or whatever and they
they kind of took turns Randy was like
yeah yeah it's pretty good dog good and
then Paula Abdul goes two thumbs up all
the way and and Simon Cowell was like
you remind me of of Rick Astley you
don't have quite as good of voice as he
does but your mind I think was basically
the I look younger than I sound good
idea that was the basis for comparison
trenchcoat yeah and I was already
trenchcoat her and I did a backflip off
a while Evan Evan took a chain-link
fence into his Michael with yours I I
think I've seen it I don't know if this
week I don't think we've talked about I
just think I've seen it on YouTube and
username at the time I had this
character that might have been on the
channel the guy wearing the huge fanny
pack yeah a fanny pack that can like
pack like two lunches you know singing
Akon which like at the time was a hit it
was like I want to love you
[Music]
I know you see me looking at you you
already know now this would not be a
very novel character but at the time I
was like oh man this care I got to bring
this troll character yeah yeah prat son
and somehow it made it on but you got
you got nixed right off the bat yeah
actually this is another secret I mean
not so secret now but I didn't actually
meet the judges but on the show as long
as you're in the room they can cut you
against the judges right and you get you
montage you made it on time so I was
talking to like the other the producer
Simon what's his head and I montage with
somebody else or another Simon but you
did appear on the show even though you
didn't meet the judges and then they
edit it so it looks like you're going
and they just cuts a reaction shot of
Randy going home they're actually kind
of generous with the reactions because
sometimes what they do and I actually
saw it in that same episode with some
other like poor guy like I don't think
he this actually happened with the
judges but they just cut to reaction of
a guy saying you suck or whatever
obvious that they were just like feeding
that to like a camera or something yeah
and then been editing it later that was
you you uh you left you had you you your
callback was during our tour remember
like we took a few days off from our
tour and you were like you've had to
flow it fly to Atlanta is that where
you're called our class
yeah very important appointment no it
was I remember going to Duane Reade with
you or whatever and like trying to find
the perfect glasses so you guys were on
tour so you had graduated by this point
really cool but you were almost there
let's just say you were no but you guys
are basically already established that
hey were the Gregory Brothers Band at
that point how did it grew into it over
the course of that tour it started out
it was like Andrews album and Sarah's
record and they're going out as two
bands and me and Michael are kind of
playing and backing him up and were and
then by the end of the tour we were
one unit we booked like weep over the
whole show the whole tour was like 50
dates 52 gigs and we had booked like wow
we've booked like the first you know 15
to 20 or whatever as two acts
Andrews Gregory and Sarah fullen and and
then we were just each other's backing
bands and after repeated dates we're
like we would show up to the venue and
they'd be like oh thank god I'm so glad
you're here Andrew but we're still
waiting on the other band I have no idea
where they are they're supposed to open
for you and you're like oh no that's us
the other band is us and we change
instruments yeah so then eventually
we're like this is too many words let's
just be the Gregory Brothers but there
was this like YouTube schmoyoho thing
that was like percolating over here on
the side and was that like at this point
just a Michael thing like I'm just doing
this on the side during the tour yeah
yeah cuz you would start you'd had some
some locally viral hits like what like
soon so you you started a YouTube
channel
you called it schmoyoho nobody knows why
I'm sure I still don't know why you
don't I was like this will be genius
I'll get all the Google search results
ever choose the name Schmo yo I just
made it up yeah and because what were
you seeing on YouTube that you did you
have videos that you wanted to put up
there or were you observing something on
YouTube that you wanted to be a part of
like uh a little of both I mean lots of
this stuff on YouTube at the time that I
had seen was just stuff like rip from
MTV because that's like before the the
big Viacom rift where they were like
pulling stuff huh so I was just like ah
look like I can watch an episode of Ali
G now upload a music video about this
local park why not
so yeah the local locally viral video
they're referring to is this video
called Jimmy Smith Park which is just
about a park in Boone North Carolina
that is like how how big what has this
huge sign like twice as big as this room
which for listeners is not very big
[Music]
sign you know like way bigger than this
ear biscuits sign if you laid the sign
down it would comprise the whole park
pretty much yeah it was this huge
yeah like itched how do you make that
local a viral every every Boone student
watch it I think that that yeah you've
got a song about the part yeah it was a
musical called Jimmy Smith part to the
park oh yeah please three rocks three
benches smiling at me a copper this edge
[Laughter]
like very yodeling oh there I'm real bad
I'm clicking mentally right now on that
and I'm just sharing it I just noticed
like last year I was getting like a lot
of like like a little bit of hate from
that video and then I clicked on the
videos like what happened about Jimmy
Smith Park and then it was a bunch of
commenters that thought I was making fun
of a famous organist named like Jimmy
Smith if you would have use anyway you
can get them you know the never deny any
sort of traction we can get on the
internet but what about space creatures
from the future what man you guys going
deep this is awesome
[Music]
[Music]
no I remember when we showed up there to
meet you I was like I the auto-tune
thing I was like this is genius this is
awesome show data rels I'm sending an
email I'm gonna fanboy a little bit but
then I was like but then we took a
little deep listen to the song original
songs yeah so you just had these things
that you were kind of creating it was
this just you were you guys collaborate
on any songs not mostly know except
space people from the future I think
Michael was composing while we were on
tour so he bounced a few things off of
us but he was recording and producing it
and what I mean what was the vision at
the time it was just like okay I'm gonna
try to make something go viral on the
internet like wait I guess the main goal
with that one was just a thing about
space people from the future
it was just having fun yeah there is no
like real hook like viral hook you know
that was like very like trendy or newsy
because because it was it was before the
day where everything is so calculated
now where if you're in a band you think
about the viral thing you can do to draw
attention back to the real project right
so it wasn't it wasn't that mentality it
was more just like hey we're trying to
do this thing as a band but I'm gonna
have some fun on the Internet at the
same time yeah and I was just learning
to edit and record so that was like me
experimenting with a bunch of stuff all
the split-screen stuff and green meaning
and and waving a keytar or and waving a
keytar did you actually play the keytar
and that or did you just wave it around
probably just waved it around okay
because what was because there's an
expose because what were you doing as a
band how time was it was there we're
kind of music were you singing as a band
was there a comedy in that uh I mean I
would say most of the songs had a sense
of humor about them but they weren't
collie dogs is straight you know it was
like it was mostly Andrews music which
is very like fulk set in sort of a in
sort of a soul Motown II
kind of way and then all the stuff that
I was writing was like kind of soul
stuff so you know just for white kids
singing soul right how you do um yeah so
I mean there were a few you know like
Evan and I wrote a song called butter on
my roll that was basically just like a
goofy love song and so there was there
was cleverness to it but it definitely
was not intended to be like a calm but
then auto-tune so give us the background
on that like the skills that lined up in
order to like physically make that
happen because there's yeah I mean
there's like a con has got the signature
auto-tune sound preety pain I think
right about the same time yeah but it
wasn't like power to the people
everybody's you could get an auto-tune
plug-in but what were you what were you
doing when you that you started playing
around with this stuff so at the time I
was interning at the studio in Hell's
Kitchen in New York and I mean we use
the technology on everybody whether you
want it detectable or not whether
they're a great singer or not just
because it was like part of the style
you know at the time I guess to that
2009 it wasn't only like to be
undetectable sometimes people just
wanted the effect because all the t-pain
songs are really popular Akon was really
popular now you'll hear that some but
it's mostly like a little bit more
hidden and I mean pretty much everybody
has used it and pops since like the end
of the 90s yeah but people didn't really
know about it until like 2009 when it
like yeah Cher and then especially in
like 2009 ish when it got really popular
well it's weird that now in hip-hop it's
they use it to actually make them sound
worse if you ask me I mean yeah cool but
it's like like that song yeah he totally
messes with it I mean it's it's complete
you know mystic like the one about the
I'm blowing up the club on a Tuesday
like that you know that song I don't
know what that was horrible I love it
it's like Auto detune I know
I don't know a little wayne has used it
like that a lot and it's kind of cool
how sometimes it sounds almost like a
tonal yeah exactly so you okay so you
were this was this was part of what was
happening and you were in the studio so
in the studio doing that a lot and I
think at the time I was doing some more
topical YouTube videos or one in
particular that was around the 2008
debates and it was a musical why and
really for no reason except I thought
that I always thought that news and
politics were funny just to kind of like
the messaging like around the around the
election season is always like so basic
even though it always felt like we
should be voting on like really like
high level platform stuff but instead
you're just talking them about like the
most basic like did you can you believe
that that guy didn't like wear a flag
tie you know that's the things you're
talking about even though you should be
talking about like oh like what what are
their tax policies or whatever that I
always just thought that was funny so I
did a musical that was like in the
debate but it didn't have any of that
kind of auto tuning in it and it did
really well surprisingly what was it it
was it was footage that was just kind of
like rhythmically so it was footage of
the debate I took Obama out and put
myself in and so it was me McCain and
the moderator and just saying a musical
and it did surprisingly well and I was
like oh let's follow it up but it'll be
boring if it's every week every debate
it's just me like singing singing at
people right you got to sing with people
I was like this this technology I'm
using that the studio is so powerful I
mean if it can make a non sing or sing
it can make especially non singer sing
people than Rican you know yeah and that
had not been done you had not seen that
anywhere I had I mean it it probably had
been toyed with around the same time but
I don't remember but it was more just
kind of recognizing it like this
technology can accomplish a lot like the
so you can correct people so thoroughly
that it could correct the speaker into I
was already making non singers saying
right yeah yeah so how easy was it once
you
got into it it was pretty tough I mean
you can hear like if you watched that
first video that would have been in like
the end of 2008 and our videos now that
were way better yeah but we'd super
lucked out because the first time I
tried it was Sarah Palin and Joe Biden
and they're actually both like pretty
good accidental singers yes I love that
term I love this I've heard you guys did
it before the accidental singer accident
what writer qualifies a good accidental
singer uh I think the sentence you just
spoke was good accidental singing
because it like held a pitch it was
supported by the breath my voice is like
mediocre right now I feel like if your
speak like a low male speaker has a
disadvantage
yeah because women women and high male
swimmers are and me female and high male
voices have an advantage honestly a good
rule of thumb is are you using your
voice like us like a singer would and
someone can be talking but they could be
talking like this and they're projecting
and using their full instrument so
sonically a lot is happening that is
already similar to singing and so then
it's just like a shorter trip to make to
match that person to a singing melody is
it true that everything you say is
technically a note like what I'm singing
now is it a note if your vocal chords
are vibrating they're making out alright
or multiple notes but if you're doing a
group like a dirty yeah that's terrible
accidental singing right yeah this is
huge I mean you can't maybe I guess this
is gonna be big but that's my point at
the time I mean you're reluctant to say
I invented this but if other people
invented at the same time in parallel
yes but I mean you you didn't see
someone else do it and you emulated it
you invented it and that's pretty
freakin amazing I mean when you when we
continue to trace everything that
happened it's it it reshaped the
Internet
the SoundCloud is turning red right now
me blushing but it's what did you have a
sense of any of that it's like I had
this I well in charge yeah when it were
first signs like oh they're good at it
this is gonna this is gonna work well
you know Michael kept doing it so you
knew that when's the first time you
heard enough you know when you heard it
was it was it VP debate in song and
dance it was out you guys were doing
something else and then it was like
Michael's like I got this thing it's on
my channel well you guys what you were
already how I was just working a day job
yeah you know during that two whole time
period we've been playing together a lot
as a band we're spending tons of time
together we knew everybody's business
and everybody's projects and stuff like
that and when Michael made the video for
the first debate we were loving we were
like this is so hilarious we you know
we'd love to help out and look like
let's all let's all pitch in so we
worked overnight together on the VP
debate and song and dance and like you
know Michael's working on the tuning and
we're working on like the video montage
or whatever and that that helped in the
sense that like you know the debate airs
at 8 p.m. or something and like
collectively we're working on it
overnight and it came out the next
morning or something like that so we
were kind of on board following Michaels
lead from that point on and then trying
to pick up different elements of the
craft or kind of self-taught on the
video side so it was during that period
that it felt like we we got an inkling
of like oh oh people think this is
interesting and and funny because they
wouldn't get views in like the realm of
like a few thousand views which is
light-years beyond whatever we would do
with you know live recordings of our
band or whatever because that was part
of the craft right part of the craft was
and continues to be but especially in
the early days was the quick turnaround
so you have to you can tell us the
process you you watch the footage you
decide on some theme that you're gonna
kind of key in on and make the chorus
out of or whatever where does this rhyme
in a certain place and then you got to
come up with a melody you know like what
what goes into that yeah it's really
tough because there's so many factors
it's is this a good accidental singer
but then if everything they say is like
super boring then we might not include
it or if somebody doesn't have a great
voice but everything they're saying is
like super interesting or entirely crazy
or like oh we have to include this so if
you hit the jackpot and it's somebody
that's like giving a very interesting
speech and they're like the Beyonce of
accidental singing like like Katie
Couric she was the greatest right and
that was like that up here by the way
yeah
oh yeah I haven't seen her but I've
heard that she's here a child of hers or
something years who's actually into this
type of Internet stuff I believe it
right and she was like I feel like with
that video the first video we did with
her it felt like the one of the first
times that we were crafting the song it
was just making quick one that was yeah
that was auto-tune the news number two
and that was I think I mean we obviously
were enjoying the debate videos enough
to keep doing them and enough for
Michael to figure out how to sort of
make this a recurring thing so you kind
auto-tune the news and then with number
two that was our first video to hit a
million and we were like pirates drugs
game is a thing yep and that had a lot
to do with Michael finding that melodic
hook and Katie Couric's voice it wasn't
just like snippets of notes here here
and there it's like it turned into a
hook and when that really landed like
people just started sharing it virally
that video broke out really big if we
all don't take old action and take it
soon
[Music]
and so okay so these videos beginning to
get traction and then when does the
perspective shift from okay Michael's
got this thing going over here in an
hour kind of contributing to to know
this is what we're going to pursue this
is gonna be the thing that we're all
doing it was that it was that video
right like I think you started pretty
much working full-time on your videos at
that point yeah after that video it was
it was we all recognize that like we
should be like all trying to put energy
into this and stuff like that but the
Creator program didn't exist in its
current form then so there was no
mechanism to be like oh clearly we're
gonna make a living off this that's
still a question mark but it was just
like people are responding to this
whether or not there's any money there
let's try to make more fun stuff and
there was pretty like traditional media
feedback from it too like we went on the
Rachel Maddow Show and and whatever so
there was sort of like auto-tune for
hire type stuff at that point right
people hitting herself into bar mitzvahs
there was definitely a sense of like
it's not like we're going to I'm gonna
be a YouTube partner that was all new I
think that was new at the time but yeah
I'm definitely gonna suddenly be riding
for jingles I was like my dream job oh
dang I can write jingles now and there
was a big piece of this was that Michael
was working with barely political at the
time oh you're working you were did you
have a job there uh no we just I worked
with him like freelance on a couple
videos but auto-tune the news wasn't
under their banner well actually they
were really generous and it's really
like the reason a big reason that that
went viral is we double posted it it
actually I I posted it on schmoyoho and
at the same time I was about to do a
collaboration with them and I sent it to
them and said hey why don't we do
something like this format it's kind of
funny to be like a mash up instead of
trying to be like super structured and
they said this is great can we just
posted it on our
we'll link to you and so they did so it
actually went viral when they posted it
and but they linked back to our channel
very generously but then you kept
putting auto-tune the news on both
channels for a while yeah we kept double
posting for probably about eight more
episodes okay and then at a certain
point you've got a branch out like I can
you know I can see and revisiting you
know you five years ago well the first
auto-tune the news number one was six
years ago and then five years ago the
first songified this auto-tune cute kids
and Kanye a simple title that blew up
more
I mean auto-tune really blew up but it
was on the barely political channels
we're really like went to through the
stratosphere I think looking at the
views mm-hmm but then you kind of it
seemed like you were you you had to
figure out a way to iterate on the
concept what we did right we did a year
of auto-tune the news exclusively and
then after that year we were like this
is a lot of work for one yeah well
actually I think the Kanye video came
out that same year oh yeah that was like
the 2009 VMAs oh yeah at the end of that
year yeah I guess and then that's then
in that next summer was when was it
which one was Trent the strut that ass
was after double rainbow yeah I think
double rainbow the double rainbow was
first no rainbow was the first like
let's take this one Obama sings kick-ass
song was before double rainbow what oh
man really yeah that was a huge one was
three it was two videos before it and
then he did auto-tune the news number 12
and then you did double rainbow song so
yeah so double rainbow was the first
time that we we were like oh we could do
this not lose yeah the Obama video was
big and it worked really well because it
was a single subject type of thing and
it's and it's also really funny because
it's pretty good accidental yeah and
he's talking about how he wants to kick
somebody's ass so that's already
hilarious
so people really like that one but the
double rainbow video was the first time
that we were like you know what we could
just look at a viral video as a subject
for something that's awesome on its own
on its own on the
awesome squared right and but at the
time like we had gotten somewhat big
through auto-tune the news but we still
felt like oh we're just another guy out
here doing stuff on the Wild West of
YouTube the double rainbow song like
took off so big that that was the first
time that we got this picture like oh
we're starting to be one of the larger
fish in this pond of you know youtubers
or whatever we can't just be going out
there and and remix and then and then
walking away so that's when we started
like trying to build relationships with
people and we reached out to bear the
double rainbow guy right because that
was the first time that you were like
doing something not political so okay
news footage is one thing but you're
like this right person who made a video
correct so you so you made that call
yeah well how did that go and what did
you say well it's like the video came
out and then it's like the reaction to
it was so immediate oh you mean when you
called the double rainbow guy Yeah right
and but it was it was after the video
came out came out we were like oh we're
just making this video Michael had it
out within a couple days of when it had
gone the original had gone viral via a
Jimmy Kimmel tweet mm-hmm
and it's like the reaction to it by the
audience was so immediate you could see
the size of the reaction and people like
I want to have this on my iPod I want to
listen to this while I wash my dish is I
want to give this voice when somebody
just punched me in the throat I thought
you were about to say that you called
Bear before you auto-tune they're like
what was the sequence of events well
that's that's what we that's what we do
now but because this was the first time
it's like we didn't have that in mind
and right yeah as of the reaction we
were like oh we got to get ahold of this
guy we like we got to try out we got to
talk this out yeah we got to talk this
through and so then it was at VidCon
actually because we put out the video
right before the first VidCon and I
think I remember as I remember we were
at VidCon being like we've got to get a
hold of bear like we need to talk with
him and like make sure that this is cool
and and we got ahold of him through like
you know the YouTube messaging
system at the time he's like the nicest
guy and he's like the nicest guy in the
world and just walking around yeah
exactly so so after we talked with him
as when we put the song up for sale on
iTunes and just went 5050 with him on
proceeds of the of the song that's at 36
million views now five years later
one two three four videos later was the
Bed Intruder song
oh yeah which guys I mean I remember
double rainbow came out here and then
you guys did the show and like it was
amazing the chills they'd be like
singing the songs like awesome
but then the you followed it up
basically with this Bed Intruder which
is now at 128 million tell us about that
because that's Antoine right that's yep
so he's a different character than bear
yeah and you would also kind of change
your policy for when you make contact
right so tell us how at the time we were
still just doing videos so we just did
the video that was probably within two
days and again I guess we felt like if
we were going I mean when the when we
realized the reception was so huge and
people and really wanted to buy this
song and own it we were like that it's
not we got a we got to connect with ya
and you're doing a favor and yeah really
so so we it was really hard to get and
it was pretty hard he's probably getting
hit up like all sides like crazy so we
put out the bat-signal like after we put
out the video and we're like oh this
video is getting a lot of tension you
know we really need to contact Antoine
see if this is cool and and if he wants
to just do the same thing we did for
double rainbow cuz we hadn't done that
again at the time so we put out a bat
signal which was just a huge annotation
classic annotation at the beginning of
our video it just said
Antoine email us at Antoine number one
hit at gmail.com
[Laughter]
but like finally we were like wait I
think this might be the real deal
it was like it was a well it was a
cousin of his right yet there were a few
dubious emails of course and I think
this one was like I am cousin like why
don't you tell me what you want to talk
to
about or whatever and I'll see if I
could put you in touch and so we got in
touch and then how did that conversation
go well I mean it went pretty well
as I recall he was like yeah let's split
it and um and I think even by that I'm
not sure if it was by that point or soon
after but he was like oh yeah that song
as my ringtone I love you guys I'm
trying to figure out you know you guys
had to start to deal with your own
success right I mean you had to figure
out well we've got to iterate on this
thing and we've also got to branch out
this is not the breadth of who we are as
artists we're also a band we also have
you know how did you start to deal with
that what were those conversations like
I mean yeah we're still having those
conversations every day about like you
know what do we want to pursue because
we we have our our main thing which is
creating sonification x' that like our
our audience love they want it they want
to see that but we still have all these
other side projects we play in other
bands and we have a second channel where
you know like our more in depth
superfans want to go see us do whatever
but striking that balance of how much
you energy you put into one project
versus another it's like a constant
balancing act and you guys were working
on a TV project for a while - right
there was a ya show that you were
developing right so I mean having
success on YouTube as you know gets it
turns into tons of asks from around
YouTube but also traditional media and
so we have guys our auto-tuning the
oscars yeah we do we that was huge we
produced a segment for the Oscars one
year which was just in our own idiom
taking clips of movies and put him into
a montage as if those movies had been
musicals it was really well received it
was in an other and otherwise somewhat
dark year for the Oscars when James
Franco and Anne Hathaway hosted and was
not well received and so I think our
segment was seen as sort of a bright
spot but I remember seeing that and I
didn't know you guys are doing it ahead
of time not like we talked every week
right you never called you you answered
that Bruno incident yeah it was so
exhilarating to see that and it's like I
either someone has totally ripped you
guys off perfectly or you act
he just did a segment on the Oscar we
got a lot of them we weren't allowed to
really tell anyone about it and and and
the way the Oscars work is that you know
they they have dozens and dozens of its
segments produced ready to go and then
you know inevitably the speeches run
long and they have to cut oh so I think
we found out like literally like right
when the Oscars went to air or something
that we were had had a good chance but
we didn't tell anyone so then our phones
started blowing up and being like as you
can imagine there is so much protocol
around making a piece for the Oscars
you're going through so many layers and
I've almost forgotten about this because
it's been three or four years now but
originally the idea was we're producing
a musical number that the hosts aren't
gonna sing and they're gonna sing a duet
with like auto-tune clips of the the
movies are gonna play over their heads
and they're gonna sing in the movie or
respond and it's like as if it's a live
musical thing that's happening it was so
complex and so so we wrote that whole
segment that's a thing that existed that
will never be seen and but it was so
complicated that okay how are we gonna
teach this to James Franco and Hathaway
so we shot a whole video of ourselves
wearing a sign that says like James and
Anna well we're we're singing the parts
like instructionally so that they could
learn it and then perform it live on
stage and then it was like this is this
is too hard like they can't they're
having trouble enough hosting yeah we're
not gonna we're not gonna throw this is
a pretty complicated segment and I
remember on one demo I played the part
of Scorsese giving them like a standing
O that in the bits so obviously it ended
up being just like a standalone thing
right right you guys obviously continue
to do more of the song application of
things and you branch out into other
areas but given the this the nature of
the internet I mean there's this there's
probably not going to be another Bed
Intruder moment right there's not going
to be another because it's not going to
have the same freshness
that auto-tuning something had three or
four years ago right
but like the shia labeouf thing comes
out like they put this the green screen
thing and I see that and I'm like the
Gregory Brothers have to songify this
what you did right what's you is that
what you're getting at well it's your
interaction what and then like okay but
but that when you see that role are you
like yes at this point that was sort of
handed to us on a silver platter
[Music]
don't
[Music]
well I guess I'm I'm kind of getting at
is like there's this because the energy
the way YouTube works has changed so
significantly they like there's this
like initial wave in which like okay
right place right time this is going to
go through the stratosphere and then
there's more like okay well we are this
is what we do is what we're known for
this is how we provide for ourselves and
we're good at it we're gonna continue to
do it but we're it's not just because
it's physically impossible at this point
given the nature of the internet for
something to be that novel right in a
way that it was 2010 I mean you're
exactly right in 2010 like the novelty
factor of that was just peak because
nobody had seen it before right and so
there was you know there was a song
crafting but then mostly was just like
what is this like I've it's totally new
and I I mean it's almost like I feel
like there was some time in in a caveman
civilization when some dude like started
singing and everybody's like oh man like
brain explosion I can't believe this in
like you know 10 years later he's like
still singing and they're like yeah like
hey why are you still singing at some
point like singing because I'm singing
yeah yeah now everybody's still singing
now it's still a thing I feel like it's
just like another you know art form that
is going to exist
and with that we'll always have like
hits and non hits you know I mean it
changed the anticipation it's and it
goes into the process because there was
probably a moment in which you know when
you were working on the bed intruder
song after having done double rainbow oh
this is this is gonna explode
and now just given the nature YouTube it
might be a little bit more like this is
gonna be really good but like let's not
get our hopes up because YouTube's
different now is that going to yea the
environments totally yeah definitely
different so you have different
expectations but even at the time there
was no precedent for either the double
rainbow song or the bed intruder song so
with you through those like yeah we
definitely had hopes like I hope people
like this but never in a million years
would we have said like wow this is a
hundred million videos for sure right
yeah you still never know right now
because the novelty isn't there
we would you know never expect a
mega-hit like that but some things do
break out and some things are really
shareable but we don't rely on that for
our day-to-day it's like oh let's just
stay in the game and be consistent and
and we can make episodes of songify the
news that are more like about the comedy
of us like commenting on stuff and then
if I want to try there something viral
let's let's do that as well but you know
our audience is still there and they
still like it so you know we've been we
made a lot of episodes this year right
and the nature of morality is shifting
to I mean it's always very nebulous
where we're all inventing it as we go
along and I'd say like some of the
biggest things we did this year are like
the the Kimmy Schmidt song and on
YouTube it's like it's doing well but
I'd say it probably has been seen the
most on Netflix and then we did this one
video for a hit record on TV that got
you know 10 million views on Facebook
and on on YouTube it's got like a like a
good amount of views but it's not like
completely blown up you know so now it's
like you never know where people like
which community is gonna run that so
what's the plan
moving forward and this like the
strategy and where does songify fit into
that you guys sit down like Gregory
Brothers meeting here's a whiteboard
weird we're mad at each other and we're
partying in were throwing felt markers
and lock ourselves in the room deciding
on stuff we schedule being managing your
schedule getting angry at each other for
Thursday's angry angry day is their
family meetings let's take it in emotion
yet there's a work meet might not work
meeting I'm talking like hey there's
some emotional tension here are there
explosions are there emotional explosion
no there's there's just like internal
angst and then one of us disappears for
a couple weeks and then we research but
I have to think that heals with it
personally oh yeah but Sarah being there
that's gotta be a good dynamic I think
that you being there I think it probably
helps with any potential friction
between three brothers right I mean it's
that's kind of don't you guys go
you guys like really have knocked down
drag out fights before I came along and
you're just on there on your best
behavior still after six years it's
primarily passive-aggressive I would say
yeah the way we like you know build up
some tension about like Andrew said
today he's over there read and read it
and he didn't do his dishes there's a
salsa bowl in the sink unwashed right
now we are we have plenty of you know
business meetings where we're talking
about okay we got these ten videos we
want to make which ones are we working
on this week you know whatever and we
you know we'll we'll go through those
with weeks of regularity without ever
talking about its feelings we did
Institute an annual meeting I recommend
this for everybody this sort of like it
is it's definitely business you know
focused where we do like the big picture
sort of like goal-setting and dreaming
and stuff and reviewing of preview at
the previous year and just this year so
so we hash out a lot they're like I've
really been pissed over this last year
about this but this year this last past
year was the first time I made us take
personality tests specific to how you
interact with other people and so we did
a little bit of that and just I mean
it's like it's stuff we already know but
what else did you determine besides
you're the only one who likes
personality - yeah pretty much that we
well we we kind of walked in on the fact
that like Michael and I are actually the
extroverts and I mean introverts in the
group Andrew and Evan are the extroverts
that but that yeah that Andrews an
initiator he's he's like our he's like
our team coach like he'll he can like
help us incur it he can encourage
something to the finish line Michael
likes to work alone which is you know
tough that you have to work with three
people I don't know what else do we
learn
that's pretty much it thanks guys and
glad it stay with you so I don't know we
you know we try to we try to go there
and kind of hash out everyone's well but
I have to say I feel like we're all
pretty lucky we work pretty well
together and this is a question that we
asked to any any groups that work
together and it's usually a duo that we
asked this question to but you know is
this a this is a forever thing we're
gonna work together in some capacity
forever or it's just like we each we you
know this is great but we've got our own
things that we want to branch out and
try I know you guys already do a lot of
things sort of you know different
projects but is there just the sense
that there's there's a natural end to it
or is it just like now this is something
wrong is going to maintain I'm really
curious to hear your answers but I'll
just answer first because that's what I
do I think none of us like to say no to
anything ever so I think that there's
just this sense that we'll just keep
doing it and do other things you know we
there's a there's like a connection to a
community that keeps us really tied to
what we're doing and then obviously like
pride and what we've built together and
being connected to one another and it's
like you've put in all of this time to
like learn how to work together and it
would be such a shame to throw it out
the window but I don't I don't foresee a
time that any of us would ever be like
I'm out except that I just had a baby
and I'm like mmm I like hanging out with
the baby more than you guys yeah there's
that but I'm still I'm still in the
office we would have to get brother
divorced if we're gonna stop bored right
yeah that's an official I know a lawyer
who can do that who specializes in
sibling divorce I don't know what are
you guys I'm really curious I mean
honestly I think it's somewhere in
between I think we will work together
indefinitely as long as it keeps working
but you know six years ago we never
would have said like oh this YouTube
thing is definitely gonna be a career
and we're still at a point where it's
like how long is this gonna you know
keep happening until the environment
totally changes
and the money doesn't work or we get you
know and offered it goes you know some
somewhere else like maybe we move from
this to another medium or another
platform or whatever it's so different
now than it was five years ago or ten
years ago that we can't possibly predict
what the career is gonna be like but
right now we still really enjoy making
videos together and so we're definitely
gonna proceed with that while we also
try to make TV over here make music over
here and just dip our toes into all the
different things well I'll keep dipping
and keep us keep us keep us in the mix
relationally we want to add other keep
us on mix relationship other data points
a lot of different ways that was my
first line to Sarraj you know that keep
me in the mix relation yeah just got one
request when you go back to Texas you'll
just keep me in the commode for nachos
anytime there it was our conversation
with our friends the Gregory Brothers
let them know what you thought hashtag
your biscuits tweet at them their handle
is Gregory Brothers not the Gregory
Brothers just Gregory Brothers because
that's a lot of letters and Twitter all
unless you go so far and that's enough I
mean why do they need Thee well I don't
me may not be able to fit the isn't
there a limit on how long your Twitter
handle can be I just thought that you
said it was too many I didn't know he it
was too many just like philosophically
or like you know is there a is there a
philosophical limit to how long a
Twitter handle should be or is there a
technical limit both and and what and do
they converge are they the same yes my
question and do you know what the answer
is because you don't seem to Gregory if
you count the letters of Gregory
Brothers I'm betting that and you add at
least at most three you're gonna get
there and if it was one less than it
would have been Gregory Brothers with a
like B are OT
H a s to get rid of the are yeah that's
about be confusing now I like the fact
that this came full circle you know when
we went up to visit them in 2009 we
recorded them we recorded an interview
with them on your iPhone
yes in voicemail and now we had about I
think significantly upgraded the
recording quality in our approach but
everything I think you know that itch
that we scratched because you had the
voice memo how you know I would like to
just do a an audio interview yeah it's
and are those still available somewhere
in full circle I think if you go to the
redolent community right they were only
community at some point it was on when
we had a blog on our website mm-hmm I
think we did it that way no no I don't
you you can try to dig those up but you
remember we also you know we also talked
to that visit you remember Allison
Fishman the voice for the voice for
Swedish meatballs or whatever she did
only ended up connecting with her on her
old rhett and Link cast live and she
taught us how to make guacamole over the
phone in which we fed to a hawk which
you weren't supposed to do because it
could kill it anyway it didn't die the
hawks okay but when we went to New York
to talk to the Gregory Brothers we also
sat down and had a meal with her and
recorded that but now we find a way that
didn't make sense you know for us just
to post a picture and an audio interview
on our website we are now doing that
I think you've read it the Gregory
Brothers in to some degree for the for
us doing your biscuits let's do that we
had the right to do that okay so they
were they were on the first ever
primordial version of your biscuits
which was just your iPhone yes and
where's ago and they were the first
in-studio guest on good mythical morning
they were that is a fact they set on
that weird futon that I had in the
garage we had our set it's not enough
room for all and Andrew wasn't there
then you know Andrew has a way of
slipping away or you know what I know he
was there I think he was there but Sarah
was Sarah wasn't there I can't remember
I can't remember either but it was also
there all Gregory's well three of them
and one of them married into it but you
know I mean we're just trying things
let's just say we're ahead of our time
yeah or that we tried a new
didn't work and now it's finally working
let's just say it'll sound more
self-deprecating we also if we would
have known auto-tune and and we would
have gone a lot further with some other
things we tried like we took people's
words verbatim and turn them into song
and we did that for Alexis Cohen the
American are saying that if we had all
attended that we would have been the
Gregory Brothers we could have been and
I'm so glad that we didn't know
auto-tune because there's they're so
awesome and then they wouldn't exist uh
that's me for some no but that's pretty
presumptuous ok so let me go on record
and saying that I'm glad that we didn't
do it because it would have sucked okay
then we would have looked stupid when
they did an awesome so thanks to the
Gregory Brothers for doing things the
right way and in a way that we wouldn't
have done and giving us all
millions of us entertainment and in not
just the past the present but also the
future were excited about what you guys
are doing and thanks for coming on that
your biscuit oh you're talking to them
right now yeah I usually don't do that
but you know what they they're gonna
listen to this right and thank you no
they won't I mean I wouldn't listen to
myself for over now the chance I'm
listening to it go up really high
because there's four of them so at least
one of them will attend them one of them
will tell it all the rest of them about
it and they'll probably divide it up
I'll take the first 25% okay you know
there's only one of them's listening to
them right so and I like to think that
it's Michael I don't know why because he
seems like he's because he's the
youngest he did they make him do
everything last oh they make him do
everything thank you guys for listening
and for staying to the to the bitter end
here with us the music's playing it is a
bitter end
it is very bitter but we'll be back at
you next week speaking into your ears
holes and canals can we say canal your
canals York analysis will be rolling up
your ear canals this time again next
week
you know romantic canoe and the time is
really whenever you so choose yeah
didn't choose it be six more years from
now what what presidents being auto-tune
right now who
[Music]
[Music]